a décidé le visage masqué evelyne
rapportent les livres empruntés il ya
quelques jours
tafer de rené et françoise bourdon c'est
vrai que ça permet quand même de pouvoir
lire comme par rapport à aux pop à venir
du tout quoi et vous le trouvez quand
même ça marche ça marche bien bah oui
apparemment ce que la dernière fois
j'avais pensé avoir rien fait et puis ça
marche et évelyne fidèles de la
bibliothèque a pu le faire grâce à la
mise en place de biblio drive un
logiciel développé pendant le
confinement par eric robert spécialiste
dans l'édition de logiciels libres et
c'est bon la réservation a été
enregistré et on voit qu'on a le rang
numéro un
tout devient en ligne et il est
important que l'usager puisse maintenant
interagir en ligne et pouvoir disposer
de son ouvrage sans forcément se disent
se déplacer en même temps que tous les
autres dans l'est dans les locaux d'où
le développement d'une application de
gestion de prise de rendez-vous pour
fonctionner comme un drive finalement ce
service de culture à emporter a donc été
lancé le 27 mai dernier ici à luynes si
certains rats bibliothèques sont déçus
de ne plus pouvoir venir déambuler dans
les rayonnages le service de réservation
était indispensable pour éviter toute
contamination
maintenant on laisse les gens voilà
revenir choisir les livres mais un par
un dans l'est dans les espaces de
consultation et voilà et la prise de
rendez vous n'est plus obligatoire mais
conseillée pour continuer à bien lisse
et la fréquentation dont le département
d'indre et loire une centaine de
bibliothèques s'est rassemblée sur la
plateforme commune de ressources
numériques nomades
cette période si particulière et est
idéal pour se cultiver à distance là on
va dire que le phénomène s'est
intensifié
pour l'aspect numérique a pris davantage
d'importance et a permis aussi de
proposer de nouvelles choses que ce soit
des heures du conte filmer ou des cafés
littéraires en visioconférence ça a
permis vraiment de d'intensifier encore
les pratiques qu'on pouvait avoir en
termes de culture numérique une culture
numérique désormais donc plus
accessibles à luynes comme ailleurs
c'est donc une formidable occasion
d'accéder à l'histoire et au fabuleux
contes et légendes du val de loire